All right, we're now on problem
number 15 on page 463.
Let's see, they have a chart.
And it says, city and noon
temperature in Farenheit.
So I'll just write
temperature.
And city A is 50 degrees, B is
33, C is 27, D is t degrees, E
is 68 degrees, F is 44 degrees,
and G is 40 degrees.
All right.
Now, so the question says, the
table above shows the noon
temperature for seven cities
designated A through G.
All right, if the median noon
temperature-- so the median--
is 40 degrees, then the noon
temperature for city D could
be any of the following
except?
So the median means what?
It means the middle number.
It means if we were to rearrange
all of these numbers
from smallest to highest, the
40 would be the middle.
So let's rearrange all the
numbers, I guess, except for t
from smallest to highest,
because we
don't know what t is.
So let's see, the smallest
is 27, then we go to 33.
Then we have 40.
Then we have 44.
Then we have 50.
Then we have 68, right?
I should have written six
numbers down, and I wrote six
numbers down, right?
And they're saying
the median is 40.
So in order for the median to
be 40, this needs to be the
middle number, right?
The middle number.
That means there need to be just
as many numbers smaller
than 40 as there are numbers
larger than 40, right?
Just the way I drew it right
now, it doesn't look like the
median, right?
Because there's only two numbers
less than it and
there's three numbers
greater that it.
So I think you see where
this is going.
t has to be someplace here.
t has to be someplace less than
40 degrees in order for
40 to be the median number.
So let's see, it says-- and
actually, t could be less than
or equal to 40.
Because even if we had another
40 here, then 40 would still
be the median, right?
Because if you put all the
numbers in order-- you know,
you have seven numbers-- the
fourth highest number would
still be 40.
So t has to be less than
or equal to 40.
So if we look at the choices,
A is 29, well
that satisfies it.
B is 35, that satisfies it.
C is 39, satisfies it.
D is 40.
And then we look at E.
E is 42, so that does
not satisfy it, so
our choice is E.
All right, problem number 14.
This one looks exciting,
and I will do it
in an exciting color.
So let me see if I
can draw this.
So I have a line on the top and
then I have a line that
goes straight down like that.
And then this thing goes
something like this and it
goes something like this.
Can I draw this right,
draw this even.
And then it goes-- well, close
enough, I think, to what they
have on the drawing.
And let me fill in all
the information.
So it says these are right
angles, this is a right angle.
The length of this is 6.
And then it tells us that
these are 30 degrees.
And it says, what is the
perimeter of the figure above?
So in order to figure out the
perimeter-- we you know this
side, we know this side, we know
this side-- we need to
figure out these two
sides, right?
These two sides.
So once we know those,
then we're set.
And you could do some fancy
things here if you wanted to
go in the wrong direction.
But you'd get the right answer,
you could make a 30,
60, 90 triangle here and here
and figure out this side and
then figure out the hypotenuse
et cetera, et cetera.
But the real trick of this is
just kind of seeing the
negative image here.
Trying to see kind of what
hasn't been drawn.
And I'll show you what I mean.
If we draw-- let's just draw
a little line here.
I think now you'll start
to see what I'm doing.
If we have a line here,
what's this angle?
Well, this whole thing is a
right angle, it's 90 degrees,
so this angle would
be 60, right?
And so would this angle.
This angle would also
be 60 degrees.
And so would this
angle, right?
Because they have to add up to
180, and if two of them are
60, the third one's
going to be 60.
So what do we know about this
triangle right here?
Well, it's an equilateral
triangle.
All the sides are the
same because all the
angles are the same.
Well, we know one
of the sides.
We know this side we made up
because it's going to be the
same length as this
side up here.
So this is going to be 6.
Well, if that side is 6, then
all of the sides of this
equilateral triangle are going
to have to be 6, right?
And then we're done.
Now we just have to add
up all the sides.
So it's 6 plus 6 plus 6
plus 6 plus 6, right?
We ignore this one.
This isn't part of the
perimeter, the perimeters are
the purple sides, so it's one,
two, three, four, five, sixes,
so 5 times 6 equal to 30.
Choice D.
All right, problem number 15.
m is the greatest prime
factor of 38.
n is the greatest prime
factor of 100.
What is the value of m plus n?
Well, without knowing a trick
here-- a trick hasn't just
jumped into my head-- let's just
try to factor them, do
the prime factorization.
And actually the easiest way to
do the prime factorization
is, well-- look, we want to get
the greatest prime factor,
and this one is actually
pretty easy.
Because you have two, and
then it's 2 times what?
2 times 19.
We're done.
That was pretty easy, right?
2 times 19, 19 is the greatest
prime factor of 38.
100 might take us a little
bit more time, right?
Because it's 2 times 50.
100 is 2 times 50.
50 is 2 times 25.
25 is 5 times 5.
Actually, that didn't take
us much time, either.
This is just a straight-- I
thought there might be a trick
here-- but this is just
a straight prime
factorization problem.
So the greatest prime
factor of 100 is 5.
You add them together, 19
plus 5 is equal to 24.
And that is choice C.
OK, let's see if I have time to
fit in problem number 16.
Otherwise I'll do it
in the next video.
Line L has a positive slope
and passes-- let me draw
coordinate axes.
So that's my y-axis, that's my
x-axis, and I'm going to drawn
another line in a
different color.
Let's see, has a positive
slope-- so that means it's
going to go from the bottom
left to the top right.
And it goes through
the point 0, 0.
So this is line l.
Line l looks something
like that.
So this is line l.
If line k is perpendicular to
line l, which of the following
must be true?
So it intersects at a
perpendicular angle.
So line k is going to look
something-- let me do it in a
different color-- line k is
going to look something like
this, right?
It's perpendicular.
I have a feeling that this is
going to go into something
that you just need to know.
The perpendicular-- if you know
the slope of something,
let's say line l's slope.
Let's say l is y is equal to mx
plus b, but we know it goes
through the intercept, so
it's actually just mx.
Then we know that line k, right
here, is going to have
the negative inverse of
the slope of line l.
So it's going to be negative
1 over mx and then plus b.
This could intersect right here,
we don't know because
they didn't tell us it goes
through the origin.
So we don't know what
b is. b could be 0.
But the bottom line is, the only
thing we do know is that
if this number is positive,
this number
is going to be negative.
And they told us that this
is positive, right?
And let's see, choice a, line
k passes through 0, 0.
No, no.
Oh, it's C, choise C.
Line k has a negative slope.
And that's all we know.
See you in the next video.